got some new music coming in not a ton
of new music
i got a lot of new music this music is
more
free this is my first independent album
i don't have labeled
management i got i got rid of the whole
deal and this is the name of the
name of the uh album is precious stones
yeah yeah and it's uh
basically it's about digging deeper
within you know
seeing the diamonds on the surface you
know you dig a little deeper and you
find those real precious stones you know
uh we've always been told that uh
diamonds are so
rare and you know they're they're
they're the hardest thing in the world
and you know you
they cost this much and i'm like well
they're so rare why are there so many of
them
you know i want to see the colors i want
to see the different cuts i want to see
the precious stones within all of us i
mean we got to look past the
we know that we know the price of
everything but the value of nothing we
have to know what it is
that's what i'm talking about what it
means to you yeah yeah can mean nothing
to someone else but it can mean the
world to you
absolutely one man's trash you know what
i'm saying so it's it's
it's digging deeper man it's important
and i felt like i dug
a lot deeper into myself and then looked
at you know
looked at myself from the inside my mind
um my mind is not structured
the fathom who we are yes take away
everything think away um do you see you
think a way every
any way that anybody could give us
information that was from a human being
take it all away and who are we
take all the weight god i know man's
information
yeah you know just everything man any
man or woman had to do with it
yeah that's take that away okay what do
you have
yeah that's oh man i'm gonna be thinking
about this for two years
oh my god listen dick i'm on all these
[ __ ] mushrooms outside
don't listen to me man
other people haven't received i've never
thought about that
that's incredible man all this means i
know it's [ __ ] too
and if i didn't have it i would be
nothing
yeah i don't know how you came up with
that thought man that was [ __ ] up
i always thought about where did this
thought come from i was how long
was something and i might say hey i want
to know something
right and that's how does that happen i
don't know the [ __ ] that happened what's
that happen
mike oh my god yeah that's gonna have me
thinking for a long time
that's not some [ __ ] he can't spring
that on me mike
[Laughter]
that's crazy man i don't know i think
about i'm on the stump
um the shrooms always tell me that [ __ ]
you're dead whoa
it killed my ego right away oh my god
but yeah
just thinking about thoughts how do you
think about thoughts
oh no oh my god
that that blew my mind you know how do
you know shame how do you
how do you know not to take off for your
clothes how do you know that's
embarrassment
all right take a dump right you know
yeah like what is how do you learn that
where does that come from
did that come about with this
i guess if you grew up in a cave and not
had anybody to
show you those different emotions and
things like how would you know
what emotions are i'm [ __ ] myself up
that ain't safe hey safe we got to stop
talking about that because i'm gonna
we're gonna get into some some weird
[ __ ] in a second
not weirder than what this world has
seen i heard this is an interesting plan
absolutely for sure it's different it is
it is um
hopefully we get through it through all
the [ __ ] we've done so far
but god is good man yeah even when he
looks bad god that's good
absolutely absolutely i mean everything
you know falls into place when it's
supposed to so
you know there's no there's no definite
way there's no plan
there's no that you know any of us could
have at all there's always
the plan was already in place no it was
written i believe
i'm a strong believer yeah yeah
you